COULD SHOOT STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS AS THEY FLED INTO THE
HALLWAYS.
>> Tucker: PHIL, THANK YOU FOR
THAT.
REBECCA BOGARD IS A SENIOR AT
MARJORY STONEMAN DOUGLAS
HIGH SCHOOL.
SHE WAS INSIDE A CLASSROOM WHEN
THE WINDOWS WERE SHOT OUT, SHE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
WHAT DID YOU HEAR?
>> I WAS IN CLASS AND THE
FRESHMAN BUILDING, AND I HEARD
GUNSHOTS, AND I DID NOT WANT TO
REACT, BECAUSE I WAS NOT SURE
WHAT THAT WAS.
AND IT WAS LIKE, WE JUST
AUTOMATICALLY KNEW WHEN WE HEARD
THAT TO GO INTO HIDING, BECAUSE
NO ONE IN MY CLASS HAD EVER
HEARD THAT BEFORE.
SO WE ALL WENT AND HID UNDER THE
TEACHERS DESK.
>> Tucker: WHAT DID YOUR
TEACHER DO WHEN THE SHOTS BEGAN?
>> AT FIRST WE THOUGHT IT WAS A
DRILL, AND NORMALLY THE TEACHERS
KNEW IF IT WAS A DRILL, AND SHE
LOOKED CONCERNED.
SO WE WERE TRYING TO STAY CALM
HIDING.
MOST OF THE CLASS TRIED TO STAY
BEHIND HER DESK AND THERE WERE
TEN KIDS ON THE OTHER SIDE BY
THE COMPUTER CART NEAR THE
WINDOW.
AND THE TEACHER HAD HER PHONE.
WE HAD SEEN HER FOR A WHILE, SHE
WAS ON HER WALKING AND TALKING
TO ADMINISTRATION.
SHE WAS ON THE PHONE WITH THE
POLICE AND WE ALL STAYED CALM
AND TRIED TO RELAX, NOBODY KNEW
WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
>> Tucker: HOW LONG DID THE
SHOTS GO ON WOULD YOU SAY?
>> FOR A WHILE, I FEEL LIKE
10 MINUTES, WE HEARD IT AT FIRST
AND WE WERE HIDING AND WE KNEW
IT WAS REAL WHEN THEY SAW THE
BULLETS, THE SHOTS GO THROUGH
THE WINDOW AND GLASS SHATTERED
EVERYWHERE.
A COUPLE OF KIDS IN MY CLASS GOT
HIT.
>> Tucker: WHERE WERE YOU?
>> I WAS HIDING WITH THE TEACHER
AND A COUPLE OF STUDENTS BY HER
DESK.
HIDING AWAY FROM THE WINDOW.
>> Tucker: WERE THE STUDENTS
IN YOUR CLASS BADLY INJURED?
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW BAD, IT WAS
HARD TO SEE, BUT WHEN I SAW THEM
LEAVING, THERE WAS JUST A LOT OF
BLOOD.
THEY WERE PRETTY CALM ABOUT IT,
BUT IT WAS REALLY TRAUMATIC TO
WATCH.
>> Tucker: THAT IS JUST AWFUL.
DID YOU KNOW THE MAN ACCUSED OF
DOING THIS?
>> I DO NOT.
>> Tucker: HAD YOU HEARD HIS
NAME OR WERE YOU AWARE OF HIM?
>> I HAD HEARD HIS NAME BEFORE,
BUT I DID NOT KNOW, I THINK THAT
HE WORKS AT ONE OF THE LOCAL
STORES HERE, SO WHEN I SAW THE
PICTURE I KNEW THAT HE LOOKED
FAMILIAR, BUT I DID NOT KNOW
MUCH ABOUT HIM.
>> Tucker: WHAT KIND OF STORE
IS IT?
>> THE DOLLAR STORE.
>> Tucker: THE DOLLAR STORE.
INTERESTING.
HAVE YOU GONE THROUGH DRILLS FOR
A SITUATION LIKE THIS?
>> YES, WE WERE PRETTY PREPARED,
WE KNOW TO STAY AWAY FROM
WINDOWS AND EVERYTHING, BUT WE
WERE TRYING TO DO THAT, BUT ONCE
THE BULLETS WENT THROUGH THE
WINDOW AND THE GLASS SHATTERED,
WE KNEW IT WAS THE REAL THING
THAT THIS IS NOT A DRILL OR
ANYTHING, AND WHEN PEOPLE GOT
HIT, THEY WERE SCREAMING IN
PANIC MODE.
THEY DID NOT KNOW WHAT TO DO, SO
WE TRY TO KEEP EVERYONE QUIET
AND AS QUICK AS WE COULD, WE
WANTED EVERYBODY TO REMAIN CALM
AT THE TIME.
I DID NOT KNOW THAT ANY STUDENTS
WERE SHOT AND THEN SOMEONE TOLD
ME IN MY CLASS THAT WAS SITTING
NEXT TO ME, BUT THE BULLETS WERE
EXTREMELY LOUD, NOTHING THAT I
HAD EVER HEARD BEFORE.
>> Tucker: DID YOU TEXT YOUR
PARENTS FROM THE CLASSROOM?
>> I DID NOT HAVE MY PHONE AT
THE TIME, BUT MY PARENTS KNEW.
SO AFTERWARDS THE S.W.A.T. TEAM
CAME AND ASKED HOW MANY PEOPLE
WERE INJURED OR IF THERE WERE
ANY DEATHS OR INJURIES.
WE TOLD THEM HOW MANY STUDENTS,
I THINK THERE WERE 30 STUDENTS
IN OUR CLASS.
SO WE ALL LINED UP ONE BY ONE,
WALKED OUT, WE HAD TO RUN AS FAR
AS WE COULD AND WE OUGHT TO STAY
CALM.
IT WAS REALLY HARD WALKING
EVERYONE, PEOPLE WERE CRYING AND
THERE WAS A LOT OF BLOOD
EVERYWHERE LEAVING THE HALLWAY,
LOOKING ON THE FLOOR AND SEEING
BLOOD AND KIDS, IT WAS JUST SUCH
A SCARY SCENE.
>> Tucker: WHEN DID YOUR
PARENTS FIND OUT THAT YOU WERE
OKAY?
>> ONCE I LEFT, MY BACKPACK AND
EVERYTHING IS STILL IN CLASS.
MY CAR AS THEY ARE MY KEYS, I
JUST GRABBED MY PHONE AND RAN.
AND MY MOM CALLED ME A BUNCH OF
TIMES.
I WAS NOT ANSWERING, SO SHE WAS
WORRIED, BUT I CALLED HER AS I
WAS WALKING AWAY.
I WAS WITH A BUNCH OF KIDS SO I
FELT SAFE AND WALKED AS FAR AS I
COULD.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE SO CALM
RIGHT NOW, I CANNOT IMAGINE
SEEING SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
HOW DO YOU FEEL?
>> BEFORE I WAS SHAKING, THE
ENTIRE TIME I WAS SHAKING, BUT
NOW I AM STILL IN SHOCK RIGHT
NOW.
IT IS UNBELIEVABLE TO ACTUALLY
THINK THAT THIS HAPPENED HERE AT
MARJORY STONEMAN DOUGLAS.
>> Tucker: HAVE YOU EVER FELT
THREATENED THERE BEFORE?
>> NO, NEVER.
I KNOW THAT THE STAFF TRAINED
US, AND IS REALLY GOOD AT
TRAINING US FOR ANYTHING,
TORNADO DRILL, HURRICANE DRILL,
ESPECIALLY THIS.
I THINK THAT EVERYBODY REACTED
WELL, AND THE TEACHERS HAD THE
DOOR LOCKED, SO THAT WAS GOOD.
>> Tucker: WAS YOUR TEACHER
CALM THE WHOLE TIME?
>> MY TEACHER WAS PRETTY CALM.
SHE WAS ON THE PHONE AND BEING
QUIET ON THE PHONE.
SO HERBIE AND CALM KEPT US ALL
CALM.
BUT WE ARE ALL THERE FOR EACH
OTHER AND CUDDLED UP TOGETHER
HOLDING HANDS.